短线交易我知道它极难成功
但是为什么我依然选择把它作为一种可能性呢
我今天想分享一下我的思考
也希望有经验的人过来人能给我提出一些建议
但我希望这些建议最好是你亲身实践的
而不是听说的
选择什么样的东西取决于目的
我的目的首先不是报复
不是说赚很多的钱
我想要的第一目的是一个相对来说自由可控的人生
自由可能是经济上的
也包含地理位置上的自由
可以选择的一种权利
地点、时间和金钱
这三点对我来说都很重要
说到这里
我就要先画一个小篇幅来讲一讲
我自己对于财富、金钱的理解
这样才方便我去阐述我的观点
首先我认为去获得财富
是有两个方式的
第一种是创造价值
为社会去创造一些价值
无论是工作还是去创办一个企业
这都是在为这个世界创造价值
那么你会得到报酬
创造价值它的在大部分情况下
你会获得金钱
而且如果方法得当的话
会获得很多金钱
但是很难同时会获得很多时间
自由的时间
除了价值创造之外
另外一个是资本的分配
你不是参与到价值创造生产端
而是参与到资本分配的配置段
就比如说投资
或者说有些人炒股投机
并没有为这个社会创造价值
但是参与到财富流动或者分配中
参与这其中去获得那些收益
资本分配我觉得
它是同时可以获得时间和金钱的
但是它对于你的本金
是有一定的要求的
比如说刚才我讲到的价值创造里面
我把它分成了有杠杆和没有杠杆的
比如说以前我是一个少儿编程的老师
我就是低杠杆的
没有太多的杠杆
我靠我的体力和我的时间去换钱
如果我有一天不干的
那么我就没有这个钱了
现在我经营了两家少儿编程的校区
我可能是用了一些杠杆
我把更多的人聚在一起
大家一起来做这个事情
我如果赚钱
我获得的收益是比我单纯去打工
获得收益要更高的
但是它仍然有一个让我很难摆脱的点
就是他如果做的好
做到最后
有可能会在时间和金钱上
达到相对的一种自由
可是在地理位置上
却无法达到这样的状态
针对我当前的情况是这样
在资本分配中
主要说的他要需要一定的本金
而这其中不像是价值创造
可以简单的分为有杠杆和没有杠杆
这个部分我认为有三种方式
可以参与到资本分配当中
第一种价值判断
最典型的就是大家天天讲的
巴菲特或者什么
投资
基于你对一个好公司
一个好价值东西的判断
去购买它长期持有然后去获得收益我的看法是他需要长时间全方位的学习当然它也需要大量本金的积累
哪怕你是100万的闲置的钱
投在里面
那么它在前面的10年
20年间
其实它的回报是相当小的
这种投资
它更依赖于你的学识
你的研究
因为实践给你的反馈
相对来说比较慢
比如你觉得英伟达公司很好
你经过自己的判断觉得很好
那在今年你投资了
过了三个月
它的股价下跌
难道就说明它不好的吗
这个时候判断不出来
你可能要经过多年之后
不断地回撤
才发现这个决策是对还是错
如果错的
它只是一个概率性的
还是说确实是自己的判断错误
它的反馈相对来说较慢
而且需要的本金还挺大的
这是第一个价值判断
我的看法
第二个叫做定价博弈
市场上虽然说一个东西
它是有它的价值的
但它的价格往往因为情绪
买的人多了
他就会涨
卖的人多
他会下跌
因为这种价格的上下波动
因为情绪的上下波动
有人利用波动去赚取收益
我今天要讲的
我选择短线交易属于定价博弈
我认为是属于定价博弈其中的一种
但剩下一种是叫做结构套利
这个点我完全没有了解过
所以我就这一点我就略过
简单的说
你这个超市的水100块钱一瓶
那个超市它是卖102一瓶
你把这个100块钱的水买过来
在那个超市去卖
你就可以每瓶水赚两块钱
大概是这样的意思
我现在讲回来
定价薄盈短线交易是其中一种
我经营企业
但是它无法在地理位置上给我自由
而且它受周遭的
整个经济形势的环境影响太大了
所以我就一直想学习
在资本分配这一端中学习一些知识
刚才我讲到价值分配
我认为它需要大量的本金
以及它的反馈很少学习的非常漫长
我也愿意学习
可是我觉得他们太漫长
就着急不得
定价博弈中短线交易
好多观众给我一些提醒
第一个他说短线交易并不可怕
只是他比较耗时间
因为你时时刻刻在看他
你要花很大的精力
很大的时间
这个违反我的原则了
因为我希望获得的
同时获得的时间是合金钱
第二个有人说
你这做几百块钱的一个仓位
你是可以控制
但是如果你是几十万美金的
一个仓位亏损的时候
你的心态会扭曲
你一定做不到
我也认同
我觉得是这样
我的短线交易方式
我是去除了这些弊端
因为短线交易
它只是四个字
但是很多人在其中
采用的方式是完全不一样的
好 第一个
我的时间是严格控制的
我只做标普500的罩盘
就下单只在那两个小时之内进行
也就是北京时间的10点半
现在是10点半到12点半这个时间
因为标普罩盘
它是流伦性相对来说
比较大的一个时间段
是比较适合
而且他的不断交易机会比较多
那这样就解决了一个做短线交易
有的人从早到晚一直看
需要耗费大量的时间我只在这个时间段做其他时间段有很好的机会我也不做那部分就不是属于我赚的钱因为我还有校区要运营我还有YouTube视频我还要去拍
所以那不是我能赚的钱
那我就放弃它
也没有什么可惜的
这样就解决了一个时间的问题
另外一个
我只做有限的几种行情
基于价格行为学
我只做波段或者突破跟随
有限的这么几种情况
那它带来的是什么
因为是日内交易
每天你都有两次或者三次
这种你觉得可能的机会
你又只做有限的这两三种情况
你的反馈其实会很多
而且很清晰
刚才我们讲的这个
我觉得的价值投资
它的反馈很慢
因为我个人本来是一个
比较喜欢实践
从实践的反馈中去获得
去学习的这样一个人
我觉得短线就挺适合我
我每个星期都可以总结一下
它反馈快
我做的行情又极少
这就导致我在每个星期
每个月的时候
都可以不断地去精进
来源于我以前的工作经历
我做过四个月全职的销售
培训机构的这种销售
它的课单价很小
几千块钱
一万块钱
每个星期
我通过自己的电话和邀约
我可以有十个客户上门
也就是说每个星期
我可以谈十多个客户
我每个星期可以反思总结十次
那一个月我就可以谈40到50的
在后面我不再做具体的销售员
我在成为管理者去面试
来自各行各业的销售的时候
我就发现了一个问题
对于那些高客单价
或者销售周期比较长的销售来说
有的人极端情况
比如说卖房
他可能一年只谈两单
卖车可能一年十几单
我在面试他们的过程中
我感觉他们的销售水平和理解
很多还不如我
三个月四个月的经验
是因为我更聪明吗
不是因为我三个月四个月
我可能谈了200个客户
但是他可能做了三年的地产销售
他可能只谈了比如说10个客户
或者20个客户
不是因为我更聪明
而是因为我反馈更多
当然有好有坏
他那成一单赚的钱
肯定跟我这完全不是一个概念
反馈快
会让我快速地去学习相关的指使
我觉得这是一个好处
在下一个
我并不非要把这个东西
做成一个复利的
就像刚才那个观众所言
当你到几万美金的时候
十几万美金的时候
你就会心态失衡
没办法遵守你的教育原则
因为你一下亏那么多
你根本受不了
可是我为什么要增加到那样的常位
如果我受不了
我就退回到我合适的仓位就可以了
这个是我在最近看到
方方土UP主
他的视频中分享
他说有一些交易员
他就只做美盘的招牌
假设如果说
他每次是做一手的ES期货
每周五天的话
三天可以打平
两天能赚到30个点的收益
也就是1500美元
一年大概就有7到8万美金的收益
他的意思是说是好些人
不一定是说不断的
我去增加自己的仓位去福利
他就靠这个部分
每周只用工作十几个小时
他就赚取了这一年
他是自己生活需要的一个资金
那剩下的时间
他可以去研究更复杂的投资
或者投机他可以去陪伴家人可以做自己真正感兴趣的事情为什么一定要去追求报复一定要去付利一定要从1万块钱干到100万干到1000万如果每年赚7万美金是我的极限
我也很满意
如果每年赚3万美金是我的极限
因为是这样的原则
严格控制的时间只做找盘
不去追求这个付利
我的极限在哪
我不知道
也许我在每个月赚1000美金的时候
2000美金已经是我的极限了
我就只赚那么多
他也是我
起码他比经营校区的好处是在
我在泰国我也能挣这个钱
我在马来西亚也可以挣这个钱
给了我弟弟上的优势
所以基于这些原因
我觉得短线交易从结果上来说
它是能同时给我地理空间
时间和金钱上的某种程度上的自由的
所以即便它再难
我觉得是非常值得去试的一件事情
如果它失败了
那就失败了
但是如果我不尝试
就因为大家说不行
我就放弃
我想有一天我会后悔的
所以这是我选择短线交易
作为一种可能性的原因
接下来一个部分
我去讲一下我2月份以来
我的交易情况大致总结
首先我现在使用的是一个400美金的仓位
我在整个2月份的交易中
盈利4美金
就最后就是没挣钱
具体数据的图片
这上面显示的是亏了32美金
因为我有几单是在黄金里面挣的
但是我统计的时候就没有统计黄金的
因为我后面是决定不做其他品种
只做标普500
所以如果只算标普500
它是亏了32美金的
大家看到
这是我这个月实际的交易情况
我觉得交易的情况比较差
当然这个视频
我不去分析这些原因
但我的感受是
我连自己的交易系统
就没有办法很好去遵守
心态总是有失衡的时候
虽然亏几十美金
对我来说
并不是说因为有压力
而是因为想到
自己的所有的东西
都要公布给大家
会有这种很想赚钱
或者说亏了钱之后
很想把它赚回来的
这种着急的心在这里面
导致我常常的不能遵守自己的交易原则
我认为最大的问题是在这里
那么在这个月我会在这个方向去改进
下一个部分我想
因为刚才说了
我总是会不遵守自己的交易原则
所以我想把我的交易的原则分享出来
这个当然你看到我的收益了
我的收益甚至只能算打平
肯定没办法去证明这是一个好的交易策略
所以更多的分享出来是希望大家提一些建议
好
这是我在月初的时候写的我的交易原则
大概是这些
那这个是我现在交易的一些原则分享出来
这些原则不知道至于有经验的人来看
我在结构上是不是有很多比较欠缺的地方
或者我定义这些原则是否没有逻辑
也希望大家讨论和给经验
好这是今天我的分享
我这个月其实有很多单笔的交易
我也觉得很值得去分析的
我觉得自己能进步
但是今天视频有点太长了
所以我可能在下周的时候
再去挑一些其中我亏损的单
或者有的是交易心态和原理
再分享成视频发出来